[Music]
so it is
9 47 a.m and
it is wednesday and wednesdays i have a
stand-up meeting with my company
i never really had standups before i
started working in tech but
basically what they are is either every
day or
once a week or however many times the
company decides
the entire team or the entire company
comes together to really just inform
everybody on
what's been going on with the company
any announcements
and all of that getting the input and
then
you can have another stand-up with just
your team which i also have today later
in the afternoon
and there everybody in the team speaks
on
what projects they've been working on
anything they're stuck on
what's to come in terms of their work
and their duties etc
and so in the morning i have the company
stand up and so you all won't really see
me talk
or anything i keep my video off because
it's the whole company and you know it's
really
more just announcements so y'all won't
really see me talk or anything but
hopefully
in the second stand up you guys can see
just a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let me take off my glasses so you
don't have to see the glare
but i've just finished the company
update meeting and
i didn't mention um any details about my
job
i work in commerce cloud development i
just started
working last month and so for the last
month
i've been going through training going
through a lot of readings oh my goodness
so many readings
i've been going through a lot of
readings and so
now i'm moving on to going through
tickets
and sprint work and all of that so
that's what today is going to look like
me
handling these different tickets and
everything and
so yeah that was the company update it's
typically about 10 to 15 minutes long
so yeah it's done now i'm so sorry for
yawning like crazy
i'm so bad at meetings i'm like just
i've always been even when i was in high
school and i was in lecture
i am so bad at meetings where i'm not
interacting and so it was that's just
i just end up yawning i'm not really
tired
but i'm just really bad at meetings
because
but no i'm going to run to the bathroom
and then
just say a little bit more about what
i'll be doing today
okay i am back and yes i'm going to be
working on some sprint work if you don't
know what sprint
is i didn't know what this print was
before i started being in this industry
a sprint is very common in tech it
is basically a set amount of time given
where the team people on the team work
on a specific task and so they can
typically be a couple weeks to a month
long and so
i have about a month's worth of sprint
work
and so i'm going to work on tackling all
of that
it's all related on working on their
sites their apps
and editing different things like
editing
headers and search components and
things like that so i'm going to be
working on different sprint work and
i am just now starting sprint work last
for the last four weeks i've been mostly
working on
like i said training and documentation
reading the company's
docs and really understanding their
system processes
the framework they use and just to
figure out
how all that works so i'm going to be
working on that i'm going to be jamming
some music i wish i could
put the audio of the music but it's copy
written but i'll be listening to either
some burner boy
um like a burner boy playlist some aphro
beats or
some cool like 2000's music like bow wow
and sierra so it'll be like a switch
between that
but in the meantime listen to this
non-copy written music
[Music]
so it's now 1 21
pm and at 1 30 i have a stand-up meeting
with
my teams and this could be a much
smaller group because you know
it's just my team so it's going to be
about eight of us and
all of us will go around say what
projects we're working on what we're
struggling with and so
i'll actually interact this time and not
you know
yawn or anything like that and so yeah
let's see what what ends up happening
i can go next um i've been also working
on sprints and
i got into an issue with my sandbox
connecting with everything so
i think i missed a step there in the um
importing process and everything so
going to just redo everything because i
think in
me trying to fix it i created more
problems so i'm going to just redo
everything and yeah hopefully it won't
take too much time
no i'll definitely let you know how it
goes thank you
okay so the meeting has ended i really
just yeah
shared that i am having trouble with my
connectivity
with the different systems we use and so
i i had to clone down a repo of theirs
and i think something happened
i think something happened somewhere in
there and so
i think i'm just going to delete that
entire folder
and just redo it all over again
so fingers crossed that doesn't take
more than just a few minutes so that i
can really
get going with everything else so let's
[Music]
see
okay so it is 2 25 p.m
and i'm feeling pretty out of it a
little bit so i think i'm going to
get dressed to go to the gym that way i
can just get some blood flowing and then
like you know
get that rush in and feel better to
continue working
on after that and so it should only be
about 45 minutes and so
let me get dressed
[Music]
so i'm just getting back from the gym
and oh my goodness
you best believe i am going to chuck
this water
oh my gosh i can't believe i forgot that
i i was so upset when i realized i
forgot it
but no i'm really glad i went got some
blood going got some you know
just getting more energized i think you
can see that more energized
um so now i'm ready to finish up what
problems i was having before and so
hopefully it doesn't take too long
especially now that
i have a quick mind and a fresh mind
getting at this so yeah let's see
okay so finally got everything to look
good everything is running well and you
know what the best code is working
code so now i am going to
eat it is oh it is okay 402
i had breakfast at around 11 i had eight
this sounds
this doesn't sound gross but i had like
a green smoothie like spinach
and strawberries and like little cuties
like tangerines so i'm gonna go
eat and i will be right back
okay this is my lunch
basically it's leftovers from yesterday
it was
just like a pot dish what was it called
i forgot what it's called
but it's ground turkey with sweet
potatoes
yellow onion and yellow pepper
it's very good it's very good
so oh my gosh
yeah i'm way too hungry for this i'm so
hungry
[Music]
now i'm just going to take a break watch
some netflix i'm currently
re-watching bridgeton i already watched
bridgeton
fun fact the male
lead is zimbabwean and that made me so
happy because i was born
in zimbabwe i am zimbabwean my whole
family
you know is zimbabwean and so
that made me love this show so much more
the fact that the male
lead isn't bobwin he grew up i believe
somewhere in the uk or maybe he's half
zimbabwe i don't remember even if it's
just a little bit i'm i'm taking it
so that made me very happy so i'm gonna
rewatch that because i can't find any
good
shows to watch on netflix i feel like
i've watched
like everything during this freaking
prayer and teacher conference i feel
like i've seen all the shows that are to
see
so if you have any recommendations i beg
of you
i i am begging of you put it in the
comments
dm me on instagram at the black female
engineer please please
tell me what to watch because i i'm
re-watching shows
now so and i have been for the last like
two months
so please help me out
[Music]
okay so now it is just a little bit
after 8 p.m
i had an impromptu meeting with one of
my
team members and so going through
certain details
on you know processes and all of that
together for the last like hour
and a half hour yeah about an hour and a
half
so i am i ate
lunch later than i usually do and so now
i'm in that weird thing where
i don't know if i should eat dinner
because i'm not hungry or if i should
wait till like 11 p.m when i feel like
i'm just starving
so i'm i'm gonna figure out
i'm gonna figure out what to do but
really all that's left
is for me to decide if i'm going to have
dinner or not and me taking a shower
me just watching bridgeton some more i
saw that the college admissions scandal
is out so i'm going to be watching that
but that's really yeah my work day so
let me know if you'd like to see
more things like this but you know leave
a like
and subscribe because i'm not about to
push out content y'all don't like
so let me know if you liked it but
thanks so much for watching
i'll see you later bye